- Right before
COVID, two years ago,
I was a speaker for
YAF, not the President.
I was speaking at a
number of campuses,
one in which was Stanford.
Three of the students who
invited me to speak there,
I spoke with beforehand.
I asked them all
sorts of questions,
but one of 'em was how
you became a conservative.
Two of the three, very normal.
But the third gentleman said,
"Oh no, my parents
are Democrats."
I said, "Well, how'd you
become a conservative?"
Well, he happened to
be in his dad's truck
a number of times by
himself driving places
and would listen on the radio.
And he found some
conservative talk radio folks
that he liked listening to.
He read what they talked about.
He read books.
By the time he went to Stanford,
his mother's alma mater,
he was a full-spectrum
conservative.
He was a believer,
he got into this.
That's a great story,
but what makes it
powerfully optimistic is
John's mother, John
Rice-Cameron's mother,
happens to be none
other than Susan Rice.
I look at that and
say, if Susan Rice,
if only given the opportunity
to hear the truth,
to hear the facts,
can actually become a
full-spectrum conservative,
there's hope for every
young person in America,
if we can just get to
them, and I think we can.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the 45th Governor of the
great State of Wisconsin,
and currently the President
of Young America's Foundation,
Scott Walker.
Welcome back to
"The Rubin Report".
- Great to be back.
Thanks for having me on.
- I'm glad to talk to you today,
because we are
only a few days out
from these very strange
midterm elections.
Strange.
Do you like my
adjective choice there,
or do you have a better one?
- I do.
No, I'm with you on strange.
I think you're right.
It's not bad, it's not good.
It's just strange, is
a great way to say it.
- What's your takeaway?
I mean, you know, everyone said
this red wave was a-coming,
I kinda was saying it myself,
but I kept saying, you know,
"You can't count your
chickens before they hatch,"
and all that stuff.
And obviously, we still
have a couple races
that haven't been announced,
as of us taping this right now.
But what's your main takeaway?
- Well, a couple
different things.
It's not as big of a
win for Republicans
as many people thought.
But taking the
House, at a minimum,
if that's where we end up
being, I think is a good thing.
'Cause it obviously slows
the horrendous, horrific,
and almost existential threat
that we have out of Washington
with the Biden administration
and his lackeys there.
So if for nothing else,
there's at least enough votes
to make someone other than
Nancy Pelosi the speaker.
That's a good thing,
to counter things.
I think one of the
big takeaways, though,
I took out of Tuesday,
was
that ideas matter,
and that it's not enough
just to say you're
against Joe Biden.
The polls overwhelmingly
showed dissatisfaction
with the way Joe Biden's acting,
the way they're handling the
economy, or not handling it.
So I think unfortunately,
a lot of candidates
on the right thought,
"Well, we'll talk
about how bad Biden is,
and we'll just run
as not being Biden."
And I think voters wanted more.
And to prove that case,
I would tell you that
where there were big wins
is every incumbent Republican
governor in the country
not only won in their
reelections, they won big,
and in many cases saved some
of the Senate candidates.
Ohio's a prime example.
J.D. Vance may not
have won that race
if it hadn't been for Mike
DeWine winning like big time.
Herschel Walker might
not have been in a runoff
in this Georgia Senate race,
had Brian Kemp not
won going away.
And you know, other governors,
Sununu in a battleground state,
where unfortunately we didn't
get as close as we thought,
New Hampshire, won big there.
Kim Reynolds in Iowa,
and obviously the two big ones,
Ron DeSantis in Florida,
and Greg Abbott in Texas.
I mean, the big
winners on Tuesday
were Republican
governors, in large part
'cause they didn't
just talk about Biden,
they actually talked about how
to lead and they acted on it.
- Were you surprised that
there wasn't more anger
to some of kind of the Democrat
"stars" of the pandemic?
I mean a Gretchen Whitmer,
who had some of
the worst lockdowns
and hypocritical moves in
her personal life during it,
or, you know, it's not like
Gavin Newsom was gonna lose,
but you know, him in California,
or even Hochul in New York,
who nobody voted for,
first time around,
because she obviously came
in after Cuomo was taken out.
But that they didn't
pay any price really.
- No, I was surprised
in that regard,
I think, particularly
in Michigan,
'cause we all
still kind of hoped
that that was a
battleground state.
I think after Tuesday,
not just in the governor's race,
but you look at even
the regent positions
in the university system.
I mean, it has sadly become
a solidly blue
state in Michigan,
almost the flip side of Ohio,
which used to be a
battleground state
and is pretty consistently
Republican now.
Although you look at
other governors, I mean,
the Democratic
governor in Colorado,
who I disagree with
on other issues,
was arguably one
of the better ones
when it came to the lockdown,
and he got rewarded
with a huge win there.
So yeah, Polis did, for sure.
And I think obviously the big
winners, Florida and Texas,
are good examples of people who,
and I would say just
governors in general,
not just DeSantis and Abbott,
but they were the
most visible ones.
And remember, detractors said,
"Oh, people are gonna die."
They had a guy dressed
up as a Grim Reaper
on the beaches in Florida,
and Beto said,
"Oh, people are gonna be
dead because of Greg Abbott."
No, they got their states open.
They not only got their
economy back on track,
their kids, if you
look at the scores,
are doing arguably much better
than kids in states
that were shut down.
But sadly, Michigan,
New York, and California
are probably now and
the foreseeable future
pretty solid blue states.
And people there,
even though the facts were
right in front of 'em,
apparently, at least
in these elections,
weren't willing to
budge from that.
- Do you miss any of the game?
Obviously, a two-time governor,
you ran for president,
you know, now you're doing your
thing with young Americans.
But do you miss the fights?
I mean, when it's election
night, are you like,
"Ah, I should have got back in,"
or, "I should be
doing this or that"?
- (laughs) My wife was actually
all excited about this.
She used to hate those nights
when I was a candidate.
She was all excited
about it Tuesday.
I'm like, "Who are you?
What have you done to my wife?"
But I don't actually, I don't
miss the campaign stuff,
the election night, the nerves.
Certainly when I saw
some of the TV ads
in Wisconsin and elsewhere
across the country,
I don't miss that.
One of the things I always
felt I would miss and I do,
are some of the people.
although I'm blessed at
Young America's Foundation
to bump into, not only
in my state, Wisconsin,
but across the country, some
of the same sorts of folks.
And obviously being with these
brave, heroic high school,
college, and now
middle school students
who are trying to stand out
on their campuses and schools
as conservatives
is very rewarding.
I think the biggest thing
I found during COVID,
people said to me,
"Oh, it must be nice
not to be governor."
And that was my
initial reaction.
But after a couple months
of fools across the country,
in my state and elsewhere,
locking things down,
as you can imagine, I just
looked at it and said,
"We could be doing
so much better."
People always ask me,
"What would I have done?"
I look at not only
DeSantis and Abbott,
but Kristi Noem is another
example in South Dakota.
I said, "I would've put
my trust in the people."
Give people information,
let them know what
the circumstances are.
But put enough faith
in the American people
and the people in each state
to let them make the right
decisions for themselves,
their families, their children.
Governors, and for
that matter, mayors
and others who did that,
their jurisdictions
are doing far better
than those that
locked things down.
- I don't know if you
happened to see it,
but there was an article
a couple weeks ago
in "The Atlantic"
about pandemic amnesty.
Did you happen to catch that,
or see any of the
firestorm around that?
- I did, a little bit.
I didn't read the article,
but I did see that.
- So broadly the idea-
- It's interesting,
looking at all the 2020-
- Yeah, so the idea of amnesty,
this idea that we should just
sort of forgive everybody
who did all of these, you know,
massive government
overreach things,
and that we let bureaucrats
trample on the Constitution
and all these things.
I suspect from a Yale studio,
you're not really in
the mood for amnesty.
- No, and I think it's,
as you and I know,
sometimes, not only in politics,
but in life in general,
when you come to a crisis,
that's when people
reveal themselves
to be who they truly are.
And we saw that
during the pandemic.
The people who not only rushed
to put the government
in control of things,
to in many ways disregard
the state and federal
constitutions, you know,
the Constitution doesn't have
a clause for an emergency.
It's there no matter what.
And there are a lot of people
who trampled all over that,
thinking, "Oh, it's an
emergency, it's an emergency."
No, that's exactly why
you have a Constitution
is so that, so, you know,
self-proclaimed emergencies
don't take the day.
That's what you have
in dictatorships
and oppressive regimes
around the world.
We don't have that
in the United States.
We should never forget that.
We should never allow something
like this to happen again.
And again, if you look back,
hindsight's always 20/20,
but I think it's
very instructive
to see the governors, the
mayors, the other officials
who again, put their faith
in, taking this seriously,
I never once thought it
wasn't a serious issue,
but who put their
faith in the people.
I have, one of
the big takeaways,
and I think you have seen this
in some of the exit polling,
was, I think post-pandemic,
there is a shift.
It's less about
conservative and liberal,
Democrat and Republican,
as it was post-pandemic
about blue-collar and
white-collar jobs.
I think a lot of
people, like my brother,
who's a manager at a
convenience store chain,
and my sister-in-law, who sells
appliances for Home Depot,
great, good, hardworking people,
they and other blue-collar
workers like them,
I think became very turned off
towards the heavy hand
of the government.
Because first it was
the place they worked at
and then it was
their kids' schools,
both of which they
were upset were closed,
versus, sadly, in the
suburbs in particular,
a lot of white-collar
employees who were like,
"Eh, I don't have
to commute to work.
My kids can each hang
out in their bedrooms,
be on their computers
all day in school.
We spend more time together.
This isn't so bad."
And they were the ones
that kind of bought into
giving these freedoms away.
I think there's gonna
be a long-term shift
that reflects of more
suburban voters, sadly,
being open to
government control,
and more blue-collar
workers and their families
who are like, "I don't ever
want this to happen again."
- Speaking of shifts,
I don't know if you've
seen any of this,
but a lot of people are
saying that, you know, Gen Z,
which is now voting
for the first time,
that they're all coming in,
and in essence, you know,
they're sort of
default leftists.
They've been taught
that socialism is cool,
that big government is good,
you should just be given
stuff and all this.
It's obviously counter to
the work that you guys do.
And I've spoke at many
Young America's events
and people are excited
about freedom and all that.
But it is an uphill
battle, for sure.
- Oh, it totally is,
because it's starting
younger and younger.
I mean, we just took over,
in addition to the Reagan
Ranch out in California,
this last year, we took
over the Reagan Boyhood Home
in the middle of the
country in Dixon, Illinois,
where we have conferences,
but we also
occasionally have tours
and school groups
that come through.
Our director recently told me
that some fifth grade students
that were there with a
class trip loved the tour,
but at one point, our
director was talking about
how Reagan, his actions,
as we just recognized
this past week,
you know, November 9th,
the 33rd anniversary of the
Berlin Wall coming down,
the fall of communism, he's
talking about communism.
And the kid said, "Well,
what's wrong with communism?"
And the guy was
like, bewildered.
And he's like, "You
know, we're taught
that that's a system of
government that helps people."
Like, no! This is not it at all.
But it's sadly what
we've seen for years
on college campuses.
We actually have a suit
against the administrators
at Clovis Community College
in Fresno, California,
where during Freedom
Week last year,
our chapter there had
posters that were approved,
pre-approved to put up.
The posters showed a woman
in the old Soviet Union
standing in a grocery store
where there was no
food on the shelves,
which sadly was pretty
frequent back then,
as it is in places like
Cuba and Venezuela today.
And it said, "Got
milk? Got bread?
Got blankets? Got anything?"
And it was obviously
making a point
about communism and
socialism not working.
And the administrators
literally took the posters down
and claimed the reason for that
was because it was
offensive to Communists.
Well, hell yeah, it's
That's because they're wrong!
It's the truth!
We've got to get the truth out,
and it's gotta happen sooner,
because the indoctrination
is happening
younger and younger
along the way.
- Yeah, I mean it's incredible
that that's leaking into
elementary school at this point,
but I suppose at some level,
none of this should surprise us.
Going back to a bit of the
racehorse politics for a moment,
you know, the big thing
in Republican politics,
or in conservative politics,
whatever you want to call it,
is sort of this
Trump/DeSantis thing
that seems to be bursting forth,
whether we like it or not.
What's your take, and what
do you think is gonna happen?
- Well, I think
it'll be interesting
just because of Ron DeSantis
just having been reelected,
he's obviously gonna
focus on being governor
in the short-term.
Someday, whether
it's 2024 or 2028,
at some point I think he'll run
and be an excellent candidate.
But that may not be the
worst of all scenarios.
'Cause I think it's pretty clear
that President Donald
Trump is gonna announce,
probably within the next week.
It'll give him a chance, and
all the rest of us a chance,
to see what happens.
If he catches fire again,
it probably makes people
like DeSantis and others
think twice about running.
If it's lukewarm
or not good at all,
maybe it opens the field,
not just to DeSantis,
but Abbott, Kristi
Noem, Nikki Haley,
Mike Pompeo, Mike
Pence, Ted Cruz,
you name it, the whole
universe out there.
And I think, you know,
as much as I don't
talk and tweet
the way that Donald Trump does,
I do think he's
earned the right,
based upon what he did during
those four years as President.
He has, without a
doubt, earned the right
to be at least at the top of
the list of consideration.
Doesn't guarantee that
he'll win the nomination
or be elected President,
but I think he's
at least earned it.
I was suspect early
on, but my goodness,
I mean, tax cuts,
regulatory reform,
some of the greatest judicial
nominations I've ever seen.
Even simple things,
like doing what nobody
else had the guts to do
and moving the embassy
from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem.
I mean, there's a whole
cross-section of things
that most of us
as conservatives,
even from a Libertarian's
point of view,
never dreamed were possible,
that this guy got accomplished.
Now, does he always
talk or tweet
or have the same tone
that many of us do?
Probably not.
But again, I like
people who do more
than just people who talk,
and for that he earns
a lot of credit.
- You mentioned
the Libertarians-
- I do think the
flip side of it is,
yeah, he's got a little bit of
a challenge though, I think,
because many of the people that
he endorsed in the primaries
either didn't win,
or like with Vance,
wouldn't have won
without DeWine.
And so that'll be part
of the equation as well.
- Right, and again,
as we're taping this,
we still don't know what's
happening with Kari Lake
and with Blake
Masters and Laxalt.
So some of this could shake out
a little bit better for him,
but we'll kind of see.
But since you mentioned
the Libertarians,
on Twitter at least,
there's always this war
with the Libertarians.
You know, basically, do we
remain hardcore Libertarians
and only vote for
Libertarian candidates?
Or, obviously, we're a bit
closer to being Republicans
certainly than Democrats.
Do we align there?
Again, these are all the ideas
that Young America's Foundation
are talking about all the time.
What do you think
sort of strategically,
for the person that's out there
that just, it's
limited government,
it's low or no taxes,
states' rights, that's it.
What do you think
they should be doing?
- Well, I think the
simple answer is
don't ever let the perfect be
the enemy of the very good.
And by that I don't
mean just universally,
if you're a Libertarian,
vote Republican;
but I do think
don't limit yourself
to solely voting Libertarian,
because while that's
great on principle,
it doesn't get things done.
I think Reagan certainly
was a great person
at bringing different
coalitions together.
I hope during my years in
office, three elections,
of which the recall was one
of the biggest in the nation,
we were able to do that and
we reigned in government.
One of the biggest
frustrations to me,
I don't know if you remember
this, but a few years ago,
Matt Bevin, the governor of
the Commonwealth of Kentucky,
arguably at the time
the most Libertarian-like
candidate in the country,
a guy who aggressively
cut red tape,
who aggressively reigned
in the government,
who cut taxes, who took on
these big issues in Kentucky.
And he lost that
election just barely,
and the margin by which
he lost to Beshear,
the current governor,
was less than the margin
of what the Libertarian
candidate for governor
got in that race.
And so to me, it's
just a great reminder.
I get it with some of these,
what some people
might call RINOs,
people who like a lot
of government spending,
who are just a
little bit less bad
than the Democrat
running in the race.
But in that case, it
was a prime example.
This is a guy that
Libertarians should love.
This is a guy that Libertarians
should want to replicate
around the country.
And yet they got
behind a candidate
who effectively set
that margin down,
and now you got a full-scale,
big spending, big government
Democrat in there.
To me, it just doesn't
make a lot of sense.
Don't do it across the board.
Make those candidates,
those conservative Republican
candidates, earn it.
And then hold 'em accountable
when they get into office.
And I think Libertarians
can make some real
inroads that way.
- Let's talk about the
other side of the coin here.
The progressives have basically
just taken over
the Democrat Party,
and I think unfortunately,
because of the results
that are kind of
wishy-washy this week,
I think they'll basically
feel emboldened.
Do you think there's any
stopping that movement
within the Democrat Party?
I would imagine,
I'm not totally well-versed
in Wisconsin politics,
but I would imagine you've
probably got some moderate,
or had some moderate Democrats
in Wisconsin back in the day.
But they all seem to be gone
at a national level now.
- Well, even in the states.
I mean, when I was governor
and certainly years before,
a long time ago when
I was briefly in the
state legislature,
but even a few years
ago when I was governor,
there were still a few
of the kind of traditional
blue dog outstate,
somewhat rural-area Democrats
who were somewhat moderate to
conservative on some issues,
but you know, were
aligned with unions
and other things along the way.
They're gone. They're gone.
Most of those districts,
it's one of the unique phenomena
is while the suburbs moved
away from Republicans
under President Trump,
more I think based on
tone than on policy,
the flip side of that is
in a lot of those
rural blue-collar areas
around my state and
around the country,
a lot of those Democrats
who'd held those seats before,
boy, this wave came in,
and good solid Republican
candidates won those seats.
So that shift has certainly
happened in Wisconsin,
but I think arguably
elsewhere in the country.
And nationally, yeah, I
mean, think about this.
Joe Biden, who ran just a few
years ago, 2 1/2 years ago,
Joe Biden on Super Tuesday
was basically
positioning himself
as a more mainstream
alternative to Bernie Sanders.
He eventually got Mayor
Pete and Senator Klobuchar
out of his lane,
the mainstream,
more moderate lane,
because he knew you had
all these other people,
you had Bernie
and Elizabeth Warren
and others in the
far left-wing lane.
But the irony was he did
that though in the primary
and then did the opposite of
what traditionally happens.
He then went out in the general
and ran hard to the left
to get Bernie and AOC's support
and basically outsourced
his agenda to them.
Remember Kamala Harris
actually had a voting record
the year before she was picked
that was further to the left
than the the self-proclaimed
Socialist, Bernie Sanders.
And he hasn't stopped since.
- What do you make of Biden?
What's going on there?
I mean, is it all
there, what's happening?
- No, and it's not just age.
I mean it's a combination.
You know, as Ronald
Reagan got older,
even post-presidency,
and obviously later past
his presidency, Alzheimer's.
If you have an inner core,
you still clung to
certain principles.
One of my complaints
with Joe Biden
far before this presidency
was Joe Biden would
do and say anything,
I mean, quite literally.
In '87, he got nailed
for plagiarizing
a Labor leader over in
Britain, almost word for word,
claiming his words were
the words of himself
and not of that Labor leader.
This guy has consistently done
or said just about anything
to hold the office of President.
He ran in the '87/'88 election.
He ran again in '08.
Obviously ran in 2020.
I think this guy
would gnaw off his arm
before he gave up
the presidency.
But I just think that's
all the more reason why he,
per your last question,
why he's not gonna back away
from this radical,
radical agenda.
He can't do it.
Because if he backs away,
he doesn't have enough
finesse to avoid a primary.
I think looking ahead,
that's probably a good thing,
if you compare it to 1980,
when we had similar
circumstances.
If he did back away,
he'd have what Jimmy Carter
had with Teddy Kennedy,
and that is a primary
from the left.
And if he doesn't,
unlike Bill Clinton,
and I think he doesn't think
he had the same problem
Bill Clinton had in
the '94 elections,
I think he's gonna have a
real problem, come 2024.
But, who knows?
A lot of us thought things
would be a little different
on Tuesday in the
elections as well.
- Right, and as of
the last couple days,
I mean it sounds, he
says he's running again.
It's just beyond imagination,
but okay, so be it.
So if you guys, if you were
showing up at a YAF event
at a college campus
that was heavily lefty,
which is pretty much
every single one of them,
what are some of the main ideas
you would want to get across?
One of the things that I've
been talking about a lot lately
are the Federalist Papers and
the idea of state's rights,
and making sure that, you know,
this experiment can
operate differently,
so that there are
different places
where things will be different.
What are some of the ideas
that you would want to get
across to these young kids?
- Well, first off, one,
I think we need to explain it
in terms that apply not only
the head, but the heart.
I think that's one
of the mistakes
conservatives have
made at all ages,
that we think and
talk with our head,
the left thinks and
talks with their heart.
We need to think with our head,
but talk in ways that
come from the heart.
And so some of our
most powerful speakers
at conferences and
increasing on campuses
are people who've come from
either not Soviet, excuse me,
communist or socialist,
Marxist-based
countries in the past,
because they can match
the logic of the argument
but tie it into
real-world experience.
We just had a woman
who came, for example,
and spoke to us, who came
from North Korea years ago,
escaped with her mother
through China up to Mongolia.
- Oh, Yeonmi Park.
She's a good friend.
And I've had her on the show.
- She's spectacular, right?
- She's wonderful.
- Yeah, yeah, she's
a prime example.
We're gonna have her
out on campuses for us.
'Cause I love the connection
of her telling her
personal story.
It's hard to argue from the left
against things that
she can vouch for,
things that actually happened.
We have a young man
speaking this coming weekend
from Venezuela.
I think we need
to do more of that
and match the logic
with the emotion,
tying the two together.
But I also think we
have to get beyond
kind of the
cookie-cutter approach
of talking in political terms.
I think you're right.
Freedom isn't just, you know,
the opposite of socialism
isn't capitalism.
Certainly it's free
market-based capitalism
is a much better route than
government-driven socialism.
But the opposite of socialism
is more than just
an economic system,
it's fundamental freedoms.
One of the ways I talk about it
is say, it's the difference
between an Uber and a taxi.
You know, taxis are highly
regulated, highly restricted.
There's usually a big fee
or tax assigned to it.
And they try to box people
out from getting into it.
That's like those on the
left who want to tell you
what to do, when to
do, and how to do it.
They put their faith
in the government.
Our counter should be
kind of like Uber or Lyft,
which is, you know,
they don't care
whether you drive once a
day or 100 times a day.
As long as you get yourself
and your passengers
safely from one
point to the other,
they're successful.
Same view as a
conservative/Libertarian
point of view.
As long as you don't hurt
the health and safety
of your neighbor,
go out and live your life.
Do your thing.
I don't want to tell you what
to do with your business.
You go pursue your dream
the way you see fit,
because we believe in you
more than they believe
in the government.
And I think the more we get
to that fundamental core story
of what America's all about,
it's not just conservatives,
it's an American idea,
the better off we're gonna
be with young people.
- Are you guys worried at all
that just the
entropy of all this
will always drag things left?
I mean, even right now,
if you think about it,
you know, there's a big
movement for school choice
happening on the right.
So more and more parents
will select out of
the main systems.
Personally, I obviously
think that's a good thing,
and they'll either
homeschool, or charter school,
or pods or whatever it might be.
But at the college level,
that they're either just
not gonna go to college,
or they will just
figure out other ways
to go into the workforce,
thus leaving the colleges, in
essence, to the socialists.
- Yeah, I think you're
right on both counts.
I mean I've said the reaction,
if you're a parent being
upset about what we've seen,
either taught or not
taught in our schools
over the last few
years, particularly
during the pandemic,
is one of three things.
Get involved, run
for school board,
take your school board over,
do something that takes
your traditional
government-run school
and puts it on the right track.
Go to a private school.
If you're in a state
like Wisconsin,
where I expanded school choice,
parental school choice
options statewide,
send your kid to
a private school
with a voucher or tax credit
or other things like that.
Or, if you've got the capacity
and the ability to, homeschool.
But you're right, in
those last two options,
and certainly when it comes
to colleges and universities,
that de facto then leaves
a whole mass of people
in the government-run
institutions
that don't have a
counter to all that.
Which is precisely why
what we're doing at Young
America's Foundation
is so important,
YAF.org if people
are interested,
and that is people
sometimes say,
"Oh, do you have a YAF
chapter at Hillsdale?"
We do.
But I'm like, "I'm not
worried about Hillsdale."
- I think you're going
to be okay at Hillsdale.
- I'm worried about the
University of Wisconsin-Madison.
Exactly, I'm worried
about Stanford,
I'm worried about Harvard,
I'm worried about Yale.
You know, I'm worried about
so many public,
government-run institutions.
And so that's why our work
is certainly not done,
even as people send their kids
to alternatives to the
government-run institutions.
We've gotta fight
every single day
on every single one of these
campuses to get the truth out.
And remember, the
irony is, you know,
free speech is something
that's protected by
our Constitution,
but it should be revered,
of all places, on
our college campuses.
Yet traditionally, that's where
we're at the most at risk.
And so we're gonna fight there,
we're gonna fight on campus
and when we get there,
one of the best things
is, we just had Shapiro,
Ben Shapiro up the other
day at one of our campuses.
He typically gets not only
thousands of kids on campus,
even on these liberal campuses,
but then we livestream.
And we put that stuff up on
our YouTube page, @YAFTV,
and we literally have
millions of people
tune into those things.
And so that's how we get
around this other nonsense,
is finding social media
ways to get around.
You know, it's the beauty
of not having to go through
a limited number
of news sources.
We can put something
up on @YAFTV
and other social media sites
and really have an impact.
That's where we get
right to the students.
Not only in college;
high school, middle
school, and younger.
- What would you say
to the high school kid,
or I guess to the parents
of the high school kid,
that care about these ideas,
but they're not ready to not
let the kid go to college
or just send them out
into the real world?
They want to send them
to one of these schools,
but then they're just simply
looking at the numbers
and they're going,
"Man, it's now $60 grand a year
to go to, I don't
know, Syracuse,
and it's $20 grand a year
to go to a state school.
Like, this just does not work."
What do you say to those people?
- Well, I'd say, one,
increasingly, there
are better alternatives
than sending a young person
to a four-year undergraduate.
Certainly if you want to be an
engineer, a doctor, a lawyer,
those are certain professions
where you have to.
But I'd think twice.
There's a lot of,
and I wish I wasn't
having to say that,
but I think between the cost,
the rising cost, which is
only going to get worse.
The so-called student
debt reduction
is only going to open the door
towards more of these
colleges and universities
upping their tuition
by $10 grand or more.
So it gets offset,
in that regard.
But I also think just the
radical indoctrination.
If you're going to go, though,
if your kid, your
son or daughter,
grandson or granddaughter, or
you as a student are gonna go,
one of the most
important things,
whether it's YAF,
College Republicans,
some other conservative group,
is surround yourself with
as many like-minded people.
'Cause you're gonna get
exposed to different ideas
over and over again.
But you want to have a
support network out there.
The number one thing we
hear at our conferences,
our students say,
"Oh, it's so nice
to be around kids
that think the same way we do."
And I know with both of my
sons, who are 28 and 27 now,
one who went to a private
Jesuit institution,
which sadly was woke as well,
the other went to the
University of Wisconsin-Madison,
which is left of Berkeley.
Both of 'em came
out conservatives
because of the people they
surrounded themselves with,
who to this day still
are allies of theirs.
I think that's
incredibly important.
- Yeah, what do
you say to the kids
once they get through it,
when then they look at
the economy, and they go,
"Man, these jobs that we're
being offered, we basically,
we can't live in big
cities 'cause rent is high,
and we do want to get out
of our parents' basement,
but seems like everybody's
going back in there."
- Well, again, that's
part of the reason why
I say reluctantly, but sadly,
that if you don't have
to be in a profession
where it requires a four-year
undergraduate degree,
I'd say find some
other alternatives.
A lot of folks, community
colleges, apprenticeships,
other means to get
into decent paying jobs
without that student loan debt.
On top of it, it's a
good reminder again,
why socialism,
communism, Marxism
might sound good to
some on the surface,
but it just doesn't work.
Not only in past history,
it doesn't work in
Venezuela or Cuba today.
It's certainly a
problem in Hong Kong.
We've seen it not that long
ago in the Soviet Union.
But even in big cities,
you see so many big
cities with the problems,
not only with high prices
and out-of-control
rent or housing costs.
You see it with
cost-of-living problems.
You see it with crime in
a lot of our large cities.
Those are all places
where you not just have
Democrat or liberal control,
you largely have radicals in
charge of these governments.
And I think that's got to
be the constant pushback,
the wake-up call.
If you're concerned
about all these things,
stop voting for people
who embrace these ideas,
because you're gonna
get more of it.
- What do you think we do
about the tension
between, I think,
what's growing between the
urban and suburban communities?
You know, Lee Zeldin obviously
did an incredible job
in New York, way better
than anyone thought.
But he did lose.
And I looked at
the map, you know,
everybody was showing
the map of New York.
And if you look at the
map of New York, it's red.
It's almost all red.
Then there's the New
York City metro area
and a little bit sort
of towards Buffalo.
That's pretty much it.
But yet, they all have
to vote for one governor.
And I think that tension
is almost intractable.
And it's not,
New York's not the only
place with that, obviously.
- No, you see it in variations.
You see it, even in the New
York metro area, the citywide.
You look at the difference,
the last three
gubernatorial elections,
I was just looking
at an interesting
map today about that,
where Manhattan,
the island there,
has gotten deeper
and deeper blue.
You see Staten Island's
gotten more and more red.
And then you see pockets based,
interestingly enough,
based on ethnic trends.
You see a lot of
folks fleeing Russia
that have come into
southern Brooklyn
that actually have made it
a little bit more
open to Republicans.
You see in the
northeast part of Queens
where you see,
according to this map,
it was some of the increases
in Asian population,
and that's made it a
little bit more open.
So you see these
divisions out there,
not only just political,
but by groups of people
coming into the country
or coming into a given region.
We see it though, nationwide.
In my state, in Wisconsin,
part of the reason why
the governor's race
was not within reach,
other than the fact that
the Democrat incumbent
spent about twice as much
money as the Republican,
but was Madison, where
the state capital is at
and where the university is at,
got much higher percentages,
not only of total votes,
but a much higher
margin for Democrats.
The suburbs were
still Republican,
but not as much as they
had been in the past.
And the outstate was a little
bit more open to Republicans.
But you see this split
between urban areas becoming
increasingly liberal;
not even just suburban,
but more rural to mid-sized
communities becoming strong,
steady strongholds, I
should say, for Republicans.
There's just a real
division in America
and we've got to get past that.
I would hope, one of the things
we talk to students about,
is countering what the left
does over and over again,
certainly on campus,
but even in society.
If they disagree with you, they
call you a series of names.
You're racist, you're sexist,
you're transphobic,
whatever it is.
Sometimes it doesn't even matter
if that's the topic
you're talking about.
That's their way of
intimidating people
out of real debate,
real discussion.
Our counter, for those
of us center-right,
can't be coming up with
our own series of names,
but I think rather pushing
this larger narrative
that really is
about unity, saying,
"Hey, I don't care whether
you're Black or white,
young or old, rich or poor.
I don't care whether
you were born here
or you legally came here
from somewhere else.
I don't care about your
orientation or anything else.
What I care about
is that you should
have the same freedoms
and the same opportunities
as I inherited and
others have inherited
from our parents
and grandparents."
That's the American Dream.
That's a bigger issue
than just conservative
or liberal out there.
And it's one that truly
does bring people together.
Because then we can start
to see, yeah, you know,
the why is what
matters, not the what.
The what will cause us
to have political and
other differences.
But if we believe in the why,
the idea that that all
of us were created equal,
that the government didn't
give us these rights,
that God gave us these rights,
and it's the role of the
government fundamentally
to protect those rights,
not the least of which
are life, liberty, and
the pursuit of happiness.
If that we agree on,
then we can debate the
specifics of the what.
But right now, sadly, in
most places in this country,
people don't even agree on
what they think the why is.
And that's a big problem.
- Yeah, it's funny,
my audience knows,
I like to end the
show with some hope,
and we actually play a lot of
Ronald Reagan clips at the end
to give people some sort
of aspirational message.
I certainly know that type
of thing will work for you.
But are you,
you sort of just answered this,
but are you hopeful
that if we can teach enough
young people that stuff,
that we will reverse this?
Because I think
what's happening is
a lot of people now feel,
if you believe in freedom,
you're hopeful in red states,
but the blue state people
are giving up hope.
And maybe they'll just end
up moving to the red states,
and it is what it is.
But the hope in terms
of a national structure,
I think is eroding.
- I'm 100% hopeful, and I'll
tell you one quick story why.
Right before COVID,
two years ago,
I was a speaker for
YAF, not the President.
I was speaking at a
number of campuses,
one of which was Stanford.
Three of the students who
invited me to speak there,
I spoke with beforehand.
I asked them all
sorts of questions,
but one of 'em was how
you became a conservative.
Two of the three, very normal.
But the third gentleman said,
"Oh no, my parents
are Democrats."
I said, "Well, how'd you
become a conservative?"
Well, he happened to
be in his dad's truck
a number of times by
himself driving places
and would listen on the radio.
And he found some
conservative talk radio folks
that he liked listening to.
He read what they talked about.
He read books.
By the time he went to Stanford,
his mother's alma mater,
he was a full-spectrum
conservative.
He was a believer,
he got into this.
That's a great story.
But what makes it
powerfully optimistic
is John's mother, John
Rice-Cameron's mother,
happens to be none
other than Susan Rice.
I look at that and
say, if Susan Rice,
if only given the opportunity
to hear the truth,
to hear the facts,
can actually become a
full-spectrum conservative,
there's hope for every
young person in America,
if we can just get to
them, and I think we can.
- So the question really is,
is Susan Rice's
son working on her?
That's really the the question
that we must be asking.
Whether we'll find out.
- Well, he's a good guy.
Exactly.
He loves his parents, he
just thinks they're wrong.
And thank God he got
exposed to the truth.
- Governor Scott Walker,
I appreciate the time and
all the work you're doing.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our Politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our Full Episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.